le site de l'hôtel bah quoi comme
terrain de jeux du back and half est
bien didier locaux et internationaux qui
se relaient aux platines et des
festivaliers venus par voie terrestre ou
maritime chaleur convivialité fignoler
dans sa bonté
certains ont même fait le choix de
réserver un hébergement sur place face à
la scène une équipe discrète ces jeunes
sont vides yeux il mixe l'image
une hémorragie
j'en ai vraiment arriver à bhl un
cocktail qui draine chaque jour environ
3000 personnes
le tout géré par un staff surprenant
moi y'a plus personne mais je me dis je
vais à la 7
les jeunes d'à peine 30 ans issus de
deux associations d'houcine émail cartel
il gère toute l'organisation la
logistique des artistes la sécurité elle
est assurée par 70 agents professionnels
toute personne qui glisse en fait ça
devient un danger parce qu'on s'est
passé quelque chose d'un an mais un
objet tranchant donc on a des agents
effectivement qu'ils sont mauvais
l'événement se tient pour la troisième
fois en martinique et son oncle
bacchanales de nuit à des
interprétations diverses du bordel nous
vient des caennais est une façon de
vivre
c'est la décompression c'est le
défoulement total donc bien sûr autour
de la musique ce gars qu'est
véritablement la musique son blog
dans ce concept novateur tout bien avant
avec la débauche non quoique on peut se
défouler mais pas de la débauche quand
même
du spectacle destra garcia artistes ce
cas venu tout droit de trinidad le
bacchanales 2016 aura tenu toutes ses
promesses